I'm Jon Snow
I am the red woman very just a book very
accurate impressions I go Asian honestly
what did they give people for TV shows
can be uh Grammys cream yeah well I'm
Greg I'm Anita sometimes sometimes
depends on the video and then we are
going to talk about something if you
guys haven't heard about this video got
hacked bigger than this so yeah habit
with spider-man according to a few
article have one up here from my
favorite looks like Collider calm going
back a movie trivia Schmoe down on
Friday by the way guys yeah live stream
on Thursday if you guys watch I got our
patreon $20 okay ah shameless plug yeah
no worry full washing my god according
to according to me dude dude the hackers
obtained when how it comes from the
coming coming saying like you go beer to
beer yeah yeah kill I really meant dude
HBO was hacked badly according to Adobe
the hackers obtained upcoming episodes
and even scripts that have now been put
online with more leaked online and
beyond that they leaked an episode of
ballers in room 104 the two biggest HBO
shows more than shoes yeah really bad
yeah but if it's anonymous email with
center reporters that said hi to all
mankind the greatest leak of cyberspace
error is happening what's its name
oh I forgot to tell it's HBO and Game of
Thrones
trying us our country yeah right nation
yeah wrong and you're lucky to be the
first Pioneer through it nests and
download the leak enjoyed and spread the
words whoever spreads well we have an
interview with him HBO is following what
now we don't know for sure that is from
the actual Hatcher we're sent that what
we do know we do know it
has been hacked this is terrible it is
so terrible god off like not in this
even what has this world come to that
they have to go in hacked HBO to get
script yeah I'm leaked information about
a show everybody loved so very much as
there's so much wrong with checking all
this time now don't get me wrong when I
heard the spider-man hack thing happen I
want her to see what these business
people were talking about and because
things that I try finding information on
it that's different any different cause
I mean it's still not good no it's not
good so weak that different what like
finding out behind the scenes
information is something but to find out
like the episode yeah scripts and make
that online it's such a messed up thing
to do to anyone involved especially
because this is Game of Thrones his most
expensive season it's you know part one
to their last couple seasons like
shorter less yeah so it's nerves season
seven ish a yes Game of Thrones a part
achievements not just is that's not it
dude it's like they can't even if they
wanted to reshoot it and rewrite it they
can't they just spent so much money on
this why would you want to ruin it for
everybody who doesn't want to find know
this [ __ ] you know and importantly - why
would you want to work as uten people
I'm sure can look it up and find out the
information right yeah totally would why
would you do that to yourself right
right
why would you ruin that for you slowly
and I feel like that sucks too because
it's like I already try to avoid when I
miss a week when I miss a we're I avoid
social media I'm like oh I can't I want
to see anything I don't know I want to
watch my show and be surprised and have
that genuine reaction when I'm watching
it and be like this is happening and
then with this it's like you're ruining
it you so many people are going to be
talking about the leaks some people are
going to actually look it up in wopsle
men you're hurting everyone am i doing
this not just like HBO or whatever
you're being a little justice warrior
for that's what you're not even I feel
like if you go and look this up you're
supporting what they're doing and at the
same time if you're looking this up
that's implying the you are a game of
Thrones fan didn't rank you're going on
your way to look this up you're looking
at the go I'm a Game of Thrones fan I
want to know what happened at the same
time though think about all the people
that have made Game of Thrones
the George RR Martin's the source
material to all the writers working
their asses off the shooting the actors
yes on Reglan vol everyone involved your
hurry and they want to give you an
experience they want to give you this
experience if I give them pay for every
single episode you watch list above
Amazon our segment would normally be
like an HBO account in some way just pay
monthly and you get access these
episodes and all they would want for you
is to enjoy the experience without
having anything ruined for you as it's
really yes yeah and the thing is some
people too will look up the leaks and
not watch the episode yeah oh well I'm
sure there's people that are like not
into Game of Thrones that are probably
gonna watch Louisa and like spray yeah I
always like just out of spite go away
very like oh I know what's going to
happen on that favorite show of yours
and blah blah basically I don't want
that I've been my self you know judo
chopping that's not how you martial arts
is it that's not how you martial art
right yeah I'm gonna have to try to
avoid everything now and it's like now I
just want him to come out just bring up
yeah oh good I don't want it I don't
want it to be spoiled I really know it
sucks to is mirin a YouTube channel you
got to check comments off exactly and I
can't tell you man like when when a Star
Wars movies coming out I can't read
comments for at least a week yeah I
heard about Han Solo okay like oh like
an hour before I watched the movies I
was reading a comment on something that
was not even a star wars videos events
like I'm the [ __ ] I'm talking about yeah
it's like stuff like that's gonna come
in like yeah exactly you know what I
think should we should do I think that
everyone should spam the internet with
false information about go around to get
back at these aiders for doing this so
if we all just come together and spam
the internet just make up some
outlandish [ __ ] about the show it's
gonna be real a big nobody was gonna do
so I feel like that's the stand we can
take existed I mean I did or not read
one Lisa and that was about grey worm
taking over the Iron Throne what oh oh
right it's actually grey worm no you
know what I John I was going to say a
bald eunuch the Varys
Arius yeah I heard he's not even a
eunuch I heard that that's all of that's
another leak that is not a joke it's a
it's a farce he's going to actually
reveal that he has a penis this old tile
Tommy he's always had a penis pin and he
secretly grandfather that he's holding
in hostage and that fittings just you
know that abused him as a child or
something that's what I heard I heard
John Seto is a closeted homosexual I
already was a very flamboyant out of the
closet homosexual and that's what he's
become right
okay by the end of the season right and
the red woman is actually his mother his
mother that that's why she was able to
bring him back exactly I can write love
mine haha and Daenerys is actually her
brother - Wow she is going to Mordor
with that week I should ruin that
important to a man and that is going to
reveal that it was in the whole dime and
that silver combs are the gold ground
thinking that Khal Drogo put on his head
that wasn't even him that was that was a
faceless man I heard the actual I know
episode this the final scene is a
10-minute montage and expanded upon
montage of Samwell Tarly clean a poop uh
is so district to bring it full circle
from the first episode of slavery so six
there yeah you guys got a little a lot
of them on we've told you drive to the
real click that notification Billy the
belch tribe I need a lion are not her
channel not I get on my channels let me
promote you alright that's only word
again you see when he can focus care
actually got that at the honey house
well it's summer dreams at Casa juice
them have a patreon check out the
patreon and the patreon so much fun it
is so fun I've hacked into it and I've
seen all the videos oh yeah guys you can
have our patron until I save you a view
all the extra car in another major okay
we actually call the videos grand like
almost everything we post is only for
the dollar tier I mean very popular
actor
yeah blow up on the spot online I have
the love food making video with Tyrone
Magnus on my calendar so good only for a
dollar you guys have to watch that